i don't even know how to begin with this
story because we just got so much going
on with the elon musk nuclear bomb on
twitter
so as many of you may have heard elon
musk this morning announces he wants a a
full buyout 100 of the platform at 54.20
full disclosure i own 22 shares of the
company not a whole lot i would like to
see elon musk fix it and if that means
being bought out and getting rid of all
the shares i'm fine with that
elon musk is right about a lot of the
problems the top 10 users barely any of
them tweet anymore several haven't even
tweeted this year but something strange
is happening even though 54.20 is above
market rate it's a premium on the rate
uh uh uh of the value of the shares and
even though elon musk is saying if he
can't affect positive change he might
actually sell off his sierras which
would be detrimental to the company
these powerful interests don't want to
sell i wonder why that is so here's the
first story we have in this because what
we're seeing is elon musk expose what
appears to be some kind of shady
dealings cameron winklevoss says twitter
is considering a poison pill to thwart
elon musk's offer they would rather
self-immolate than give up their
censorship programs this shows you how
deeply committed they are to orwellian
control of the narratives and global
discourse scary
elon musk responds if the current
twitter board takes actions contrary to
the shareholder interests they would be
breaching their fiduciary duty the
liability they would thereby assume
would be titanic in scale what a
freaking stud it's just great the the
thing that's most inspiring about this
is generally speaking
mo money mo problems right generally
speaking we were talking about this a
little earlier
as people get money and get and
influence and power they they just they
get timid they they get risk-averse and
this guy is gambling
41 billion
on a really important politically
significant troll
i i think it's more than that though you
know he called the babylon b when they
got suspended and the story apparently
is he said did you guys really get
suspended over this joke they said yes
and he goes i might have to buy twitter
well also i think wow i mean
sorry just elon musk has got let
put this away he's got 280 billion
dollars towards his net worth
if you had 280 bucks
and someone was like hey this really
important thing is 50 bucks yeah you
know you might be like yeah it's 50
bucks it's a lot but you know for him
well it's even better than that because
it's not as though it has no value so he
buys it for 50 bucks which he's not
going to have to do i think his actual
plan is
offer them 50 bucks they're going to say
no he sells off his 9.2 percent he
crashes the price of their stocks now he
comes in and buys it for 20 bucks takes
it private fixes it re-lists it on uh
the new york stock exchange 12 18 months
later doubles his money so he gets to
both uh do the greatest probably social
good for free speech that anyone's done
in our lifetime and probably double his
cash on the whole on the whole affair
yeah and i also want to say when twitter
is threatening to self-immolate and
destroy their company we have to take
that seriously because we've seen them
do it before
like we know they're capable of it
twitter yeah i'm just completely
destroying any value within their own
company my understanding is that before
2016 twitter was losing users
they had changed their their metric for
how they calculated users from like
something like daily active to monthly
active so that you know because the
average person was using the platform
less they said okay well if they use it
once in the month then but it's been a
while so you've got to fact-check man
that one because i've been tracking that
as much but when i see this idea that
twitter would self-immolate i'm like
yeah because i think the real issue for
these investors is power political power
it's more valuable than cash well it it
is political that's the word we have to
use we you know we we always make fun of
this sort of build your own twitter
build your own google uh no they're
ensconced in power there was a time at
the beginning of social media when there
was competition we're way past that
they've exploited legal liability
protections they've teamed up with the
government and they've defrauded their
users so they're we're stuck with these
guys so now there's this third option
which is don't build your own twitter
just buy your own twitter and uh you
know when we talk about political power
we usually think about the government
we live in a republic in a republic you
govern yourself with speech you engage
in speech in the public square if some
bozo in silicon valley is controlling
all the speech in the republic and
censoring very important people in that
republic you don't have free speech you
don't have a republic it's the most
important thing for our form of
government in years yeah there's an
important you know this term fiduciary
duty
maybe not common to everyone who's
listening essentially what it means is
if if you are in a position of
responsibility for someone else's
investment then you have an a legal
obligation not just a moral but a legal
obligation to put their interests ahead
of your own interests and in publicly
traded companies this typically means
the executives and it means the board of
directors these are people who because
they represent
in a sort of lower case our republican
sense they represent the average
investor the retail investor they have
obligations the our our friend vivek
ramaswamy i think is so good about this
he talks about these companies you know
part of the story is that today vanguard
took an outsize stake in twitter so that
they would actually be the biggest
shareholder and elon would no longer be
uh the number one shareholder vanguard
along with blackrock and one other state
street yeah yes
they owned 22 trillion dollars worth of
the s p 500 worth of the top 500 uh
companies that are traded on the on the
stock exchange
what they are essentially is using your
money money from your 401k from your
roth ira money from your your pension
account they're using your money to
amass power for themselves to act
against your interests and i think vivek
rightly points out it's actually
probably the greatest
abuse of fiduciary responsibility in all
of human history and i think that's part
of what elon is
i mean very clearly up against he's up
against the you say these deeply
entrenched uh powers that be or these
deeply entrenched powers against free
speech
it's literally three entities yeah so uh
the daily wire you know you're launching
kids content
are you insinuating you're gonna launch
financial investment and holdings
companies to challenge this machine
there is nothing that we will not do
i'm just i'm imagining it's like you
know 20 70 and people are like oh i
gotta run to the daily wire to cash my
check
when you're out can you go to the daily
wire to pick up a a large pizza yeah
yeah and then uh i'm gonna but i'm gonna
stop at the daily wire to fill up my
tank before i go meanwhile down in the
caribbean on an island called god kingia
i mean ben has been offering me payday
loans since i started at the company you
know 50 points on the yeah
if they were to uh refuse this buyout
and then maybe do their investors wrong
what could they expect what kind of
reprisal
well i think that heretofore none it's
never occurred to any of them that they
could be held responsible i think what
this is the of all the tweets that elon
musk has put out in the last several
weeks about twitter this is the most
interesting one because he's essentially
saying i am one of the people they have
a fiduciary duty to by not joining the
board elon did not place himself in a
position of fiduciary responsibility
which leaves him with the with the
actual legal right to act against the
financial interests of twitter and i
think what he's telling them is i will
personally sue them out of existence if
they violate their fiduciary
responsibilities but but it's a lie
you know i mentioned the the trump thing
the platform dying because when trump
joins the platform goes nuts all of a
sudden people have a reason to use it
and be on it alex jones for instance
they have banned people to the point of
irrelevancy it's not fun anymore i
stopped taking the platform seriously i
post such absurd nonsense half the time
but back when there was a real million
followers on the platform it's weird to
me
to me too i posted a hairless rabbit
once and i'm like why are people
following me but they do and it's fine i
just maybe that's it maybe the
irreverence and the uh you know the
absurdity is something worth following
but my view is i used to use this
platform as a utility for journalism
right and now because of how how nuclear
how radioactive the platform's become
how awful it is it's it's effectively
worthless but
i think maybe twitter realized what or i
should say assume what a lot of media
companies did that culture war is money
as much as the left likes to accuse any
one of us of being grifters yeah the
left has been doing what's called
mission-driven storytelling long before
any conservative right-wing or
libertarian person figured out what was
going on all of these digital media
companies in the early 2010s realized if
we get political we make money and then
they have the nerve to call everybody
else here's the thing that's fine you
know obviously at the daily wire we we
have a point of view we have a series of
biases
but we own those biases if you look at
the tradition of journalism in america
you know the the tennessee newspaper
used to be called the tennessee democrat
if you go back to the time of of the
earliest presidential elections john
adams and thomas jefferson you know they
they wouldn't run for office they would
have looked down on that instead they
they owned and
and marshaled newspapers to actually be
their political instruments that's
always been the history of journalism in
this country until the post-war
consensus and then we came up with this
absurd notion of like objective
journalism
which
which is a paradoxical kind of concept
in and of itself i think it's very good
that the new york times is so far left
it's very bad that the new york times
won't just admit and own their biases
right if they would just tell us yes
we're on the left and that gives you
know that gives you
uh a series of expectations when you
read our content doesn't mean that we're
gonna
that it's okay to be completely
polemical or you know to actually be
propaganda outlets you should tell the
truth but you should let us know from
what point of view you're telling that i
i agree except the issue is when big
tech platforms embrace that well but
again if twitter would own its biases if
youtube would own its biases that would
actually create a market for
alternatives but the problem is that
they lie about their biases i i disagree
i think conservatives know twitter hates
them and what do you do parlor gab minds
getter yeah no one's going there because
there are only two reasons to be on
twitter and they they matter twitter is
the smallest big tech platform it's why
elon can make this kind of play on even
though he's the richest man in the world
still takes a lot for one guy to take
down a big tech platform there are two
reasons to be on twitter one is to get
into fights with celebrities it's super
fun it's great anyone can do it the
celebrities bite that's the one reason
the second reason is because it sets the
news cycle so
not a lot of people actually use twitter
and they never really have but all the
right people do all the right people do
and so it's it look i'll own it that's
how i write a lot of my shows i see
what's trending on twitter i it's and
it's how a lot of news articles are
written now and all of the blue check
journals are on there and so if you can
control the narrative on twitter you're
really controlling the narrative
throughout most of the mainstream media
speaking of you mentioned vanguard state
street and blackrock has three entities
essentially controlling the world if you
really look into it you start to see
that they own each other that there's a
lot of the same people this is from wall
street zen uh state street is the
largest individual shareholder of or
let's get this right vanguard is the
largest individual state street shared
holder
with 32 34.26 million shares
representing so vanguard owns 9.36
percent of state street wow and it gets
deeper and deeper the more you look into
it thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00 pm and don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and if you want more unfiltered and
uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time
you